you know one of the things that struck
me about barbecue and I was talking to
several pitmasters and the one that I I
focused on and some depth was ed
Mitchell he's a very well known
pitmaster who's in Raleigh and actually
now is has a new restaurant in Durham
called Q it is african-american and and
goes way back with barbecue and he says
something really interesting to me he
said the two most integrated experiences
in his life the place where race
divisions broke down was Vietnam where
he served and barbecue barbecue and
Vietnam transcended race and his
experience and nothing else had done so
and I thought that was really
interesting and when I was talking to
historians of barbecue and we now have
historians of barbecue they said that
even during the tensest periods of
racial strife during the civil rights
movement if the good barbecue place in
town was black White's wanted to eat
there and they would and if the good
barbecue place was white blacks would
line up at the takeout window and they
would want to eat there and that it was
it just kind of was too important to let
the normal racial divisions stand in the
way barbecue is is is something that
blacks and whites in the south share
this probably at least in ed Mitchell's
view goes back to the the the culture of
tobacco which we northerners don't
really appreciate I mean we we know
cigarettes are bad for you and we
demonize tobacco and it was a you know
subsidized crop and that was crazy thing
to do but the fact is the culture of
tobacco is quite beautiful and when you
brought in the tobacco in the fall it
was kind of all hands on deck
and blacks and whites would work
together doing the harvest pulling the
big leaves you had to hang them up in
the tobacco barns which are these
beautiful structures with lots of slats
to let air through and it had to happen
really quickly and and you built a big
oak fire to basically cure the tobacco
dry it and smoke it a little bit and in
the course of doing that which which
happened overnight you were accumulating
all these hot coals and you're feeding
the fire and you're shoveling out the
coals and it and the tradition developed
Pig using those hot coals so you dig a
hole in the ground and you take those
coals and put him in the bottom and
you'd get a grate and you slowly cook
the pig and everybody would eat the pig
together well I can wait together again
something that didn't happen any other
time and Ed Mitchell had a very
nostalgic view of this this whole period
and in fact at his restaurant he had an
artist to a mural of barbecue through
history and they're very tender scenes
of the tobacco harvest and barbecue so
it's a really deep part of the tradition
in the south is generally recognized as
a black contribution to American culture
that it was slaves who passed through
the Caribbean and in the Caribbean they
saw people cooking animals over pits on
these you know these sticks and they
also picked up in the Caribbean seeds
for hot pepper red pepper and that
became an important flavoring for the
pork and barbacoa is what what they
thought they were hearing in in the
Caribbean and that became barbecue so
it's it was a black contribution to to
southern American culture
you